the greatest and the most influential
people across the globe are very clear
about their philosophy use your mind
there's no super computer more powerful
than your mind but if you don't have
great software for it it becomes
unwieldy we haven't done a great job in
Western culture of teaching how to feel
emotions label them and then how to work
with them need motivation watch a top 10
with the believe nation what's that
belief nation it seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from having trouble
performing under pressure as a surfer to
becoming a high performance coach for
CEOs Olympians and athletes around the
world he's Michael Gervase and here's my
take on his top ten rules success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one let pain motivate you you said that
every great change starts with pain and
I found that really intriguing
it feels dark it feels heavy when you
say that but it's that's where my
experience that it's accurate is that
the reason people change is because of
pain the reason we grow is because we
get uncomfortable and we embrace being
uncomfortable but being honest with the
pain that we feel is usually the prime
mover for people to do the work that is
necessary to push to the edge okay so
there's a difference between pain and
suffering there is a difference between
there we're we're all suffering we all
have suffering we all have an emptiness
or dark place or corners inside of our
spirit in our mind that are not
fulfilled and watered and full like we
we all can relate to that and when I'm
talking about pain I'm not necessarily
talking about suffering but
acknowledging our suffering being in
touch with the pain that's enough to say
when you're really honest that's enough
to say I can't do this I don't want to
do this anymore
like this is not the person I want to
become and be on a regular basis if
that's the case if that assumption is
right then as a loved one my job is to
help you get real and experience those
places as often as you can so that you
make that the declaration to say no no
no that's not okay for me to feel and be
this way on a regular basis so let me
pull on that thread just a little bit
further it is healthy and necessary to
feel all of the human emotions but we
ask people what do you want in life most
people say I want to be happy wait hold
on now if grandma dies do you want to be
happy that's it like really when your
child is sick do you want to be happy no
no I think the answer is that we want to
feel all of the human experience to its
fullest but never lose ourself in it but
to experience all of it and so we're
getting into the weeds of some very
esoteric
non-scientific thinking right now but
the practice is that if I care about you
deeply the mistake I can make in your
life is to help you feel like it's all
okay like all it's okay it's okay that
you're drinking and driving and you
killed a fourteen-year-old that's no
problem like you'll do better next time
no the work is to say well what's this
like for you to feel that pain so you
make the commitment to say no no I can't
do this anymore
and that's when it becomes really real
rule number two live fully in the
present moment what do you think is if
the main thing that holds people back
from high performance when it matters
the most well I think there's two parts
to that question you know you add the
one that matters the most and that's a
really important nuanced esoteric phrase
and I love this phrase when it matters
most because if you listen to ESPN or
you listen to Fox Sports or you listen
to any of those you know types of shows
they'll say that a game defining play
defining moment and there really isn't
such a thing and so when it matters most
is now it's not later it's not the
Superbowl it's not your Everest it's not
the pitch that you're that you're going
to give to a VC firm that's not the
moment the moment is now and it's always
now and it's now again and if we are
present it's now again and it's always
now and so the idea is that there's no
such thing as a moment later that's more
important than the one you have now
because again this is very esoteric if
we were to strip away your ability and
my ability to live in this present
moment then we don't have life right
it's the absence of life yeah but what
happens for most of us is that if you
think about this moment a little bit
like a raindrop like it's moving okay
and eventually it'll crash death if you
will but like this raindrop that's
moving we can be on the edges of the
raindrop or we be right in the center
we don't ever leave our raindrop are you
unique ratings up but when we go to the
edges of the raindrop it's like we are
not fully in the present moment
and so what gets in the way anxiety you
know worry
what do they think of me what if it goes
wrong yeah
do I have what it takes am I gonna
embarrass myself am I gonna let people
down you know so that anxiety is a real
condition
it's estimated that well the research
suggests at 15% of Americans suffer and
that's the word from anxiety the
estimate is probably more like 30% mm
suffer and it's a mental disorder and
anxiety by definition is the excessive
worry about what could go wrong so
that's at the root at this batson what's
the opposite of anxiety groundedness
yeah sense of poise and presence
focusing on what could go right yeah
well not even not even that but like yes
right so if if anxiety is worrying about
what could go wrong an anecdote for that
experience is focusing on what could go
right and what could be fantastic living
in gratitude that's right yeah which I'm
obviously you're familiar with but the
essence of it is coming back to the
center of that raindrop that esoteric
thing I'll talk about like that falling
raindrop to time your ability to be
right in the center and what what does
that mean that you're grounded you're
present your your mind is on time with
what's happening and so you've heard
great athletes talk about the game slows
down you know it doesn't slow down
that's not what happens is that our mind
becomes fully syncopated at the speed of
life and more on time and so when we're
finally on time it's such a relief like
oh my god this is this is the speed of
light this is amazing yeah and so we
don't have ever have the power to slow
down time we just have the power to
increase our ability to be on time all
right now in this moment then the next
moment thing that's mode yeah the
worried mind is behind time or ahead of
time rule number three be open to being
coached how can we achieve a high
performance mindset when maybe we don't
have a great coach like that or someone
who's powerful in our lives that maybe
isn't doesn't emit the best energy
that's a great question is that such a
good question
okay so some of you have not had the
opportunity to have people in your life
that get you and understand who you are
and and maybe they're not sophisticated
in the way that they guide you it's a
it's a nice thought to think that we
become the average of our five most
intimate relationships
financially spiritually education you
know like we become the average of the
people around us and so I don't know I
don't know a way to the word I'm missing
the words to say to share with you the
importance of having people that get you
and that have been down the journey and
they want to help you be better so being
available for being coached is part of
it and then understanding the process to
coach others is the gift you give in
return to pay it forward and so I don't
have a clear answer other than maybe
maybe being open to being coaching to
being coached by people that have
accumulated and understand and reveal to
themselves a sense of wisdom and there's
wise women and wise men and being open
to that is really a wonderful accelerant
to you becoming who you're meant to
become
it can't happen from reading you're not
going to get it in a book reading is
great you know it's a it's a it's a
center to acquire knowledge but moving
from knowledge to insight is something
that is really important and let's never
forget ever forget that you are your
greatest coach you are with yourself
often when you're present at least and
the inner dialogue that you have in the
relationship you have with yourself was
taught to you you didn't just come into
the world with that software it was
taught to you and the good news is if it
was taught to you you can change it you
can discard that part of you and those
parts of the conversation that are no
longer fitting and you can upgrade rule
number four invest in relationships we
want to be around people that somehow
give us the sense that guy when I'm
around that person I don't know they
just I just feel better they make me
better somehow let's say it's you and me
and what I want to feel from you is that
you've got my back you understand me and
that when you're making decisions it's
not just for you it's for me as well and
so a rising tide floats all boats the
relationships that go wrong or sour is
if I'm on the side of this relationship
I'm like do I trust that he's making
these thoughts or moves because it's
right for him or
me and the thus our relationships are
the one where it's really just good for
you and I'm just casualty in your in
your experience so what we do a head of
time is we invest in the relationship so
for example the Seattle Seahawks the
product is football so just like a
business you've got products for your
businesses as well and but we are
relationship based organization is if
coach Carroll is here he'd say that's
how we run the organization a
relationship based organization and the
output is football and that we found
that to be incredibly valuable because
we don't do none of us do this thing
alone and if we're really gonna go the
distance and really step into the
frontier to do the amazingly difficult
challenging things we need to lock arms
to stay in the trenches long enough and
what happens for most people is we lock
arms we say oh yeah let's go get it and
then we lock arms and as soon as it's
hard the brain kicks in and a the
survival mechanisms in the brain are
stronger than the thriving mechanisms so
the survival mechanisms are very light
up and what do we do we save our own ass
and we unlock our arms and we take care
of ourselves that is how people fray in
rugged and stressful environments
emotionally stressful environments we
unlock and so the extraordinary able to
stay the course locked arms because
their mission minded they've they're
really clear about what they want to
experience and they bet on each other
well number five my personal favorite
find your philosophy so I needed a
mentor when I was growing up and I'm
thankful what's up Gary
like I'm thankful for Gary he helped me
out in so many different ways even
currently today and so one day he says
hey Mike I want to introduce you to my
mentor oh great I didn't know though
such a thing is like a grand mentor like
am I ready and so you know this moment
as okay here we go and it was this but
to my surprise it was this a small you
know two three bedroom two bedroom three
bedroom two bath home and it was well
manicured and it was this Pleasant like
78 82 year old woman comes out
I was just so pleasantly surprised like
okay this is gonna get good because you
just had that sense of wise woman
and it's the setting that you would
imagine the shag carpet was a little bit
long the drapes were just a little bit
you know
you know outdated and so we sat at the
table and she's pouring me tea and and
she says you know welcome and so
interested to meet you then we sat down
and she said so tell me what you're
about
yeah so okay well what well the things
that are most interests well okay let me
start this way and she looked at me and
she looked at my mentor and she said
thought you said he was ready I am I I
am ready like what wait wait no no no I
want to answer that and she grabbed my
tea and she said you know when you're
ready sweetie I'd like to share this to
you with you yeah so I was like super
embarrassed in that moment like I
thought I'd let my my mentor down and
you know it was like this really intense
experience Wow how old were you I was at
that point I was right after it was like
26 27 somewhere in that range and so I
didn't know what to do and so it was
this awkward moment but I knew that I
had I was not prepared to even answer
the most basic question who are you and
so that's where that's where I just want
to anchor that because I think that that
captures what most of us feel like a lot
most people don't feel like they know
who they are
yeah and so I had this dramatic moment
for me but you know I think it's a
really important process to go through
so let's call a personal philosophy but
then let's extract one one level out
from that the greatest and the most
influential people across the globe are
very clear about their philosophy the
greatest movers and shakers and change
makers are spiritual leaders and
political leaders for the most part and
now we're starting to see business
leaders you know to do that what was
Confucius your philosophy what was
Buddha's philosophy what was Jesus
philosophy they're really clear Jesus
was and I want to oversimplify a
beautiful set of traditions but Jesus
was more about love and service Buddha
was more about you know
that all people are suffering and then
so let's work through compassion to live
with loving-kindness what was Martin
Luther King Junior's dr. King Junior's
was about equality you know it Malcolm X
equality totally different tone totally
different approach mother Teresa Helen
Keller what was Helen Keller's like okay
I'm gonna go for it like I deserve to be
educated as well she changed the
educational system so the most
influential people were very clear why
because they lined up their thoughts
their words and actions it's a the thing
that matters most to them and that's
what a philosophy is about everybody
already has one you have one I have one
whether we could articulate it at
knifepoint in a dark alley totally
different element right and so I think
that that's a night nice litmus test
like could you get it out in front of a
deranged person who's got a knife to
your throat like could you do you argue
that clear what you stand for and do you
have your personal philosophy so the
tactics there's three ways to get clear
be around wise people and have
conversations about philosophy and
wisdom right be around them if you don't
know one go try two they're rare but you
know maybe pray about it maybe talk
about like fine wise people in your
lives or become one okay you can watch
videos of them I read their books to get
started you know yet and yes start down
that path nice nice job you know and
there's something about being in their
presence if you can that is different
course you know horse okay and there's
you know synagogues and churches and
there's folks that you can find these
people and they don't have to be
spiritual they can be secular as well so
be around wise people write journal you
know there's something about forcing
words out of your native tongue all the
words of your native tongue to write
down the words and to have a forcing
function to choose words that matter
like there's something about that and
then the last the third is and all of
them are equally important is listening
so mindfulness practice so listening to
it's one of the most ancient mindfulness
traditions is asking yourself it's a
it's called a constant plate of
mindfulness ask yourself the question
Who am I and just go down that path Who
am I and you'll learn you'll learn some
ugly things you'll learn some wonderful
things and you'll really learn who you
are and so those are three ways rule
number six harness your mind if we have
three minds about ourselves we have a
negative mind a positive mind in know
mind and the work for us as performers
is to be aware of negative mind what
those types of thoughts and then work to
get over to positive mind so what is
negative mine negative - stuff like
self-critical pessimistic there's a
sense of worry or frustration or inner
hostility that's all negative mind stuff
and then when you have awareness of that
you're in that mind or in that camp do
you have the skills to get over to
positive mind which is optimism and
focusing on what could be and they fully
engaged in the present moment and if you
can hang out in positive mind long
enough and just hang in that space
eventually by accident you can slip up
into no mind and no mind is you we all
know that space its flow state where
there's like no thoughts and it's a
complete engagement in infusion between
you and the environment and near craft
and you're just accessing everything you
need to access in the right way and the
right with the right tone and that flow
space or I'm sorry that no mind space or
flow state is there's such a sense of
all with it and that's why it's
considered the highest state for human
performance use your mind there's no
supercomputer more powerful than your
mind but if you don't have great
software for it it becomes unwieldy and
so if you have great awareness of how to
trigger the abilities to hang out in
positive mind long enough and we're not
talking about like hey everything's
great when it's not that's not what
positive mine is it's having the
discipline to focus on what's good to be
have the discipline to lock in right now
even when right now is boring or even
when right now is really difficult that
would be the software to program you to
be and to pursue your frequency
increased frequency of you being at the
highest state you can be in tell me
that's not an asset to an entrepreneur
effort or a corporation that you go into
now you become a real asset a real asset
and it's more than hard work hard work
is everybody's gonna work hard
and if they can't work hard they don't
get to stay on the world stage very long
so hard work is it's not overrated like
you've got to work hard but if you work
hard and it's not intelligent because
you haven't harnessed this amazing
computer it's like it just gets really
any fit it's just inefficient and and to
create enough momentum to create global
change or regional change or whatever
the changes that you want to have for
impact it's this is a really important
process if you will rule number seven be
a writer of thoughts there's only a
handful of primary emotions and
unfortunately we're not we haven't done
a great job in Western culture of
teaching how to feel emotions label them
and then how to work with them you know
we don't have I didn't have that course
I don't know if you did and I didn't
have a course on how you know the basic
mental skills work how to label them and
how to train them so we haven't done a
great job of doing this in the education
platform and if there's only three
things we can train craft body in mind
like why are we not training the mind
like why are we because the way that
thoughts and emotions work it's like a
bang-bang experience they happen like
right next to each other and there's
some conversation about what comes first
is it a thought then emotion or is it an
emotion than a thought most people in
the field would say of psychology would
say it's thought that emotion the way
that I think about this is that's like a
rider in the in an elephant so the rider
is the thought and then as soon as the
emotion wants to run because the thought
that maybe the rider scared he's having
scary thoughts or sad because he's
having a lot of sad base thoughts that
it's when the elephant wants to go when
the emotions run you're not controlling
that thing your job my job is to be the
rider a thoughtful aware rider of
thoughts and when we're able to be aware
of our thoughts then we can guide and
negotiate our thoughts so they don't run
while ultimately there's a meta
awareness that takes place where when
you train awareness and if we I'd like
to get into that conversation with you
when you train awareness of your
thoughts emotions bodies sensations and
your environment awareness of your
environment those four things we become
more finely tuned so that we can choose
great thoughts we can harness our
emotions we can feel our body sensations
and use them to facilitate
clear thinking creative thinking or
great output and when were more aware of
the unfolding unpredictable environment
around us we can course correct and
adjust and pivot and that makes all the
difference in the most intense
environments in the world whether that's
an emotional intensity vulnerability or
that is you know center court whatever
sporting environment that we're talking
about rule number eight practice
gratitude Martin Seligman did a
wonderful piece of research at AU pen
that just writing down at the end of the
day three amazing things that you
experienced has a significant impact in
life satisfaction it can it can impact
your relationships with others if you
are depressed people that came into his
study stabilize their depression people
that were not depressed that came into
their study after a I think was one
month three month and six month
follow-up they had a significant overall
increase in their overall life
satisfaction it's as simple as
brightening out three amazing things
right and so that's one way to train
optimism ingratitude rule number nine
build self-confidence understanding the
mechanics of confidence is really a
great understanding and so if we unpack
how confidence works it's really
actually pretty simple confidence comes
from one place and really one place only
most people believe that confidence
comes from past success and that's not
accurate
it comes from what you say to yourself
and so at any given point in time we're
having a conversation we're having a
dialogue with ourselves and if we're
saying things that are beating ourselves
up it might get us good it might you
might get good at something but you
might not enjoy who you are when you
arrive there so at any given point in
time the dialogue that you have with her
with yourself or with myself that what
we're doing is we're speaking in ways
they're either building confidence or
destroying confidence so confidence
comes from what you say to yourself and
becoming aware and mindful of your inner
dialogue is really at the center of
being able to grow to be able to develop
to be able to pursue potential and it's
a skill that we can teach it's a skill
that we can develop and if we have a
better sense of it we can guide our own
minds
towards those conversations that build
so when we are asking people to increase
their awareness of their own thoughts
great now what do we do with it
it makes sense that we want them to
guide towards a positive direction but
that's not always intuitive and easy
once you know we're familiar with our
own patterns in our mind and sometimes
it really takes a coach to coach how we
think the coach properly to adjust our
own thoughts and our parent when we hear
our children or the athletes that were
working with and we hear how they're
thinking about something and we have a
grounded perspective in life we have we
can recognize it we can hear that oh
that's not a great way to think about
something then we can take a moment and
take a beat if you will and help them
think about it in a different way and
that's perspective shifting it's giving
them a very specific way to purge or
shift the way that they see themselves
in the world and rule number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
practice efficient breathing competitive
mindset precedes excellence and that
competitive mindset is trainable it's
not just words that we can throw around
there's actually ways to train it so for
calm one of the ways that you train it
is through breathing if you want to
relax your system just a little bit one
deep breath is the beginnings of being
able to do that if you know that you get
a little too amped up in some types of
situations and then you say to yourself
well I'll just breathe when I get there
you're way too late and so it's this
this consistent process of training your
mind to train your body to be able to
relax on command and that takes time and
that takes practice and those of you who
who struggle maybe with public speaking
or sharing things that are intimate this
would be a beautiful practice to begin
and it's not more complicated than
setting your timer for maybe two three
minutes maybe six minutes and just
follow your breathing and that would
also be the beginnings of a mindfulness
practice so you can bridge the two
together so we look when we're working
with competitors and we're looking at
how they naturally breathe just in
conversation when they start breathing
up here it's like they're closer to
choking than you can imagine and if you
just take a test for yourself and you if
you just took a deep breath right now so
just you can do it privately and quietly
do you start your breath here or do you
start it here naturally babies will
start it here and it's the most
efficient breath down here because you
get the lower lungs activated and if
we're getting into the game of high
performance what we're talking about is
being extremely efficient with our
systems the most efficient we can be and
breathing up in your upper lungs is
really inefficient and it brings us
closer to the opportunities that where
we start to decelerate our ability to be
progressive in thought and progressive
in form and so we want to accelerate all
that by having effective breathing but
you have to Train it
now I've got two very special market
surveys bonus clips on how to find your
path and learn from failure but first
it's time for the three questions I want
to make sure you're moving from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your business or life
so with these questions write down the
answers for yourself talk about them
with a friend or leave them in the
comments below here we go question
number one what is your philosophy
question number two what pain is
motivating you to succeed and question
number three what three things are you
grateful for thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much loved see
you soon and enjoy the bonus clips
I think that most trajectories in life
begin with some sort of pain I grew up
here in California and my first sport
was surfing hmm and I was there's free
surfing and this competitive surfing
there's two types of surfing and free
surfing I was a good little you know 15
year old free surfer meaning when it was
just me and mother nature no problem
like it was really good you know in a
man out there yeah right like a wave you
I could figure it out well enough with
the boys like it was fun and then as
soon as competition happened and there
was people on the beach and those judges
and now as yeah the whole thing was
happening that I felt like a shell of
myself
and I'm a 15 16 year old kid at this
point shaking out in the water and you
know surf that I'm super comfortable one
and there was one day where a surfer
passed by me and we were in a heat there
was only three guys out in the heat and
he paddles by me now he's like a grown
man and he pals by me and he says
Gervais you gotta stop thinking about
what could go wrong I thought I said how
the hell does he know it's in my head
that's it like I couldn't feel my feet I
couldn't feel my body it was
disconnected to my board and so like a
good competitor he didn't tell me what
to do yeah yeah he just told me not to
think about like with all the things
that I was worrying about so I sat for a
minute and I said okay well if that's
the case let me start thinking about
what I wanted to have happen and so I
just kind of mused and you know created
some imagination about that about what
it would feel like to surf at my best so
that was the first introduction looking
back with hindsight that I had to sport
psychology and and I got out of that
heat and I said you know there's
something to like how my minds worked it
screwed up my mind screwed up like I
can't be myself as soon as there's
people watching and judging me right and
so call it performance anxiety call it
whatever you want I didn't have command
in my mind and I didn't know there was
such a thing as sports psychology but I
knew that the mind and my craft were
there was an intimate link at that point
and so that's what started it that
intersection of pain of not being able
to authentically express what was inside
of me and that's what kind of took me
down this path
with mistakes with losses with failure
that's where we learn how to get better
that's where we learn how to
become more proficient at what we're
doing so failure in a moment is
something that helps in that process so
if we can structure opportunities where
people are met with a challenge where
they might fail they might make a
mistake and they might not be proficient
it's part of the sting it's part of the
pain that allows people to grow to move
forward altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary v-d-j Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video